Speaker 1: . All right, so a ton of you sent
me news articles and clips and audio of this
crazy anti vaccine rally that took place in
New York City.
I don't know.
I mean, listen, I understand that.
I think in some sense it's surprising to some
people that this is going on in New York City
because New York City is such an overwhelmingly
liberal place.
But, you know, it only takes a few crazies.
And in particular, based on the interviews
I saw, some of these people were coming from
other states anyway.
There was some wacky woman from Pennsylvania
saying she's protesting against vaccines in
New York because she believes soon the mandates
are going to come to Pennsylvania or whatever
the case may be.
I'm going to play some of these clips and
I want to make sure everybody understands
these are funny, like it's OK to see these
as funny.
And also recognize that because of it, the
very unfunny reality of the continued covid
spread and possible inability to ever get
to herd immunity in any real sense may come
as a result of the fact that these people
exist.
Here's one woman ranting.
Let's just look at these.
I think she has a baby with her.
And I can't tell if it's a baby.
It is a baby.
OK, look, maybe like it was a dog in a carrier.
No, she has a baby and she's here ranting
about how terrible vaccines are as we see
kids increasingly in ICUs with covid, you
know, I mean, it's like there's no language
that can even adequately express the absurdity
of this.
Let's get into the first clip here and, you
know, maybe get the kids out of the room.
These clips are disturbing.
Speaker 2: I cannot afford to let my girls
grow up in a world where the government is
allowed to force an experimental injection
into their body.
Unidentified: I want to
Speaker 2: leave you with two thoughts.
Speaker 1: A USA chant, drowning out the insane
anti vax rhetoric.
What a countryfolk.
OK, yeah, so so that's that I don't even really
know where this next clip kind of fits.
And this is more about the tone than the substance
or more about the flavor than the material
or something like that.
They did the national anthem.
And this is this is another just weird.
This is really a cultural thing where whether
it's a blue state or a red state, they'll
have an event for anything.
It'll be a mike pillow rally.
It'll be an anti VAX thing.
It'll be an anti mask protest out in a parking
lot.
We covered this out in the parking lot, the
anti mask protesters.
I think that both the Pledge of Allegiance
and the national anthem.
So this is just watch your ears, watch your
ears.
But this is these are the sights and sounds
of the anti VAX rally with.
Yeah, and it keeps going, really, you know,
this is how you fight tyranny, right?
Unidentified: Into the.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
I love you, New York.
We are.
Speaker 1: Guys, what do I even say about
that, right?
I mean, what you know, we have.
I let's just move on to the next clip, OK?
I don't even know that the next one necessarily
needs any introduction.
Let's listen.
Speaker 2: Just as surely and I love a sign
in here as discrimination based on race, gender,
age, sexual orientation, religion and ethnicity
have led to misere policies that discriminate
against the unvaccinated.
Will do the same thing here.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
So as you can tell there, the the idea is
to analogize that discrimination by a business,
for example, on the basis of race is bad.
It's also illegal or discrimination on the
basis of gender or sexual orientation, although
discriminating on the basis of sexual orientation
is legal in many states or religion or ethnicity
or whatever, it's the same as saying, hey,
you got to be vaccinated to come in here because
you present a public health risk.
Being black and going into a store doesn't
present a public health risk.
Being gay and going into a store doesn't present
a public health risk.
Being unvaccinated does.
And so the analogy is, of course, terrible.
And by the way, being vaccinated or unvaccinated
is a choice.
Now, in a sense, religion is also a choice.
And we've talked about this before.
Should religion even be protected as a class
and on the basis of it being a choice, you
could make the case that it really shouldn't.
On the other hand, there's the argument that,
well, it's such a part of such a core part
of what the United States is based on.
It's a base based on freedom from religion
as well as freedom of religion.
And, you know, I'm not going around saying
remove religion, but you can make the case
that what we're really trying to focus on
here is not discriminating on the basis of
immutable conditions, things that are just
who you are.
And choosing not to get vaccinated is not
an immutable characteristic.
So the analogy is completely wrong.
Last clip here.
This is sort of a medley.
This was put together by the recount.
It's really good.
All of these clips are actually from the recount
Twitter account, which has done a really good
job covering the stuff.
This is a medley of the anti-tax rally in
New York City.
Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: This is not an inside Beck's rally
to force an experimental injection into their
body.
They're not vaccines.
They're poison vaccines.
This isn't a vaccine.
This is some kind of a bio pharma injection.
Speaker 1: Well, it is an injection.
It was made by pharma.
I guess the the prefix bio applies.
I think we're maybe talking about a distinction
without a difference there.
That that's maybe my favorite moment.
Here's another guy.
This is sort of a Keanu Reeves type guy saying
something very, very important.
Speaker 2: Ramires, I am a socialist proudly.
You don't get many of those in this movement.
Speaker 1: Yeah, so people booing the socialism,
but cheering for the Antibalas now that's
that's actually a really interesting thing
to talk about for a I think for eight years
on this show, for a while we've covered other
backs, movements.
There's never been anything like with the
covid vaccine, but for example, the measles
and tiebacks movement we've covered and I've
explained and we've looked at this phenomenon
where you see these anti measles vaccine enclave's
in really red areas and in really blue areas.
And the reason is that left wing anti vaccine
right wing activists have kind of been pulled
together for different reasons.
The right wing anti vaccines don't want the
government being involved in public health
campaigns and vaccine requirements and vaccinations.
OK, the left wing activists are skeptical
of Big Pharma because they're skeptical of
lots of types of corporations and they end
up together.
And that's super interesting where these really
are strange bedfellows.
Let's look at that again.
This is an anti vacs socialist who says I
am I am here and I am anti vaccine.
And he actually gets booed for at least initially.
Speaker 2: My name is Garrett Ramirez.
I am a socialist practically.
You don't get many of those in this movement.
Unidentified: Discrimination based on race,
Speaker 2: gender, age, policies that discriminate
against the unvaccinated will do the same
thing.
This is a trick to get us to have digital
IDs.
They don't know science, but they know marketing.
Speaker 1: Now, that's wrong, it's sons of
bitches, it's like attorneys general, it's
not son of a bitch is unless you have, I guess,
multiple moms.
I don't know.
Anyway, that's a very technical analysis there.
This is delusional.
This is really dangerous, of course.
And politics makes very strange bedfellows.
And all we can hope for is that the public
health campaigns and the vaccine requirements
that are being put in place make it just much
easier to go and get vaccinated than to do
anything else.
And I still maintain that.
If we'll talk, by the way, about Delta Airlines
and vaccinations on the bonus show today,
I still think that one of the ways to most
quickly get more people interested in vaccines
is for airlines to require them in order to
fly, maybe an issue we will take up again
in
the future.